I've been aware of it for a long time and turned away from me
Oh,
I'm not the one who became the catcher I feel the label
[Music]
a
Ah, it
seems that power is coming out of my body
What happened isn't strange
[Music]
We're in Shinsui, so
the trajectory of Kamisui doesn't happen to me The special thing is you at night I
can't be the shadow of that extra
star  I
don't have to worry about what's going to happen anymore
I'll take you over my hero's head
Night with you
I ok I'm
different from when I was in that cave
I can't
be a star anymore  I can use God's shop for a while,
so it's okay
, how
can I climb with you
What you want
I'm
strong and kind, and
instead of a night loved by everyone, I
'll
see the stars together  I'll be a star instead of you
Rophie
I'm sorry q 0 I'm
not a woman
It became